are you tempting fate if you stay up too
late
true this show makes you snicker but at
the cost of your ticker
a new study says for optimum heart
health you should go to bed between 10
and 11 p.m not am emily
researchers say your risk of heart
disease goes up 12 if you fall asleep
after 11 and that risk increases to 25
if you go to bed after midnight and if
you're awake for five days straight
you're on a bender with cat
i'm fun
which by the way it was never mentioned
in the song after midnight only good
things happened after midnight remember
we're gonna lay it on the line
is that how it went shut up greg other
more important risk factors include
things like stress depression and
working for a cuomo
but i guess researchers will do anything
to avoid telling americans to lose
weight now for half of the country our
show airs after 10 pm which means our
viewers are literally killing themselves
to watch this show we have the best fans
you'll all be dead soon but i hope it
was worth it
[Applause]
all right what do you think about this
cat you work here do you feel guilty
people are oh we should salute these
heroes
yeah okay we should salute them but also
i i think it's norm i mean i've never
been to bed
before 11 without the assistance of
medication yes exactly
yes
does anybody does anybody do that if so
how yeah so i i don't know i i just i
don't buy it i don't think it's real i
don't think this study is real i think
uh uh emily
emily i think that that sleeping is a
skill that one has to learn to be get
you should you're oh you should if you
can find it the right way to sleep your
whole life changes am i right emily
that's what they say
two points number one i feel like the
reason that this works is because people
who go to bed later are doing probably a
higher proportion of bad things so like
everything
sorry so like everything they reduce it
to like the one data point and then
forget everything else to your point
like are you staying up late doing lines
and eating shake shack and then my
second point is that don't go together i
don't know and then one time
yes i met a real nocturnal like a true
nocturnal someone who's internal body
clock like forever since they were a
child like an owl
but a human yes and they they became a
driver because she basically was like my
like to your point she said i was trying
to force myself against my
circadian rhythm whatever it's called
forever and only when i became a night
driver did my did all of a sudden my
world open up she solved the problem
where is she now
she sounds fun yes yes
so you
okay it's all right that was a good
story i know
how important is sleep to you
uh as an athlete we've always talked
about how important it was get your
eight hours so it became like really
important but we tend to stretch well
eight hours like say i go to bed at
three i get up at you know two so as
long as you get your eight hours in
you're good you gotta get your full
eight yeah but uh you know as you get
older when you're younger
you can be a little more wild but as you
get older you tend to you got to get
that if you're going to be active you
got to get that eight hours in so um it
was always been instilled you just
again these studies go
there's no point to him it's ridiculous
i really feel like this is
kimmel and colbert and ah they're like
listen listen we're not saying don't
watch but if you do you'll die
[Laughter]
good strategy
but they are also on and then when you
get charged as a serial killer yes yes i
will testify but to be clear yes not
because i want you to go to jail because
i'm not going yes
i know i could count on you cash what do
you make of this do you buy this
research i feel like i was lied to
because basically i was told that i was
going to be testing this theory live
during your show and i took seven ambien
on the amtrak on my way up here and i'm
really effing struggling right
so i don't know what you just asked me
but i'm just saying yeah
[Laughter]
i i i test so many things about
melatonin is interesting but you get
crazy nightmares take a little low dose
of that stuff makes you nuts beer is
good too beer yeah
no beers beer did then you wake up two
hours later you gotta pee wait melatonin
is natural so
okay i thought someone was gonna have
the guts to say it but i know she
doesn't watch so i'll say it i go to bed
to avoid the conversation
i
literally you wanna hear about my day oh
my god i gotta get my eight i gotta
oh okay how many guys pretend they're
asleep on the couch they don't have to
watch reality tv
you don't have to collapse i know she's
here with you
[Applause]
men there you go hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else